général n'aurait jamais imaginé finir ma
carrière comme les pouces d'un écrivain
pantouflards
qu'est ce qui te rend pas
je m'ennuie je pourrais le de tellement
de gens les petits vieux par exemple les
unijambistes
les gens disent
ça fait plus d'un mois que le professeur
a disparu le professeur l'ensemble
c'était un génie il prétend avoir
découvert le secret de l'éternelle
jeunesse
je crois qu'elle n'a jamais donné vous
sont 82
il gère via un câble dans la piscine ce
n'était pas un accident
je vais pouvoir traquer les meurtriers
de canon vient peut-être la raquette
ressouder se passe quelque chose de
louche dans cette qu'il voulait pouvoir
me l'a fièrement
n'ont ils rien de nouveau je te rappelle
que mon arrière arrière grand mère
tonkinoise avait des dons alors si cette
famille j'ai un plan
personne ne m'a entendu parler des
professeurs manceau nous n'avons pas de
méthode miraculeuse
jusqu'aux plus qu'à faire on n'est pas
là pour se faire tirer la peau mais
l'isère il s'agit d'enquêtés et bien
d'autres
encore
il faut pas que vous risquiez là ils ont
tous noté
une petite fosse est là ils veulent
s'approprier le secret du professeur
l'instant ils sont prêts à tout pour ça
à partir de maintenant peu denses et moi
prenons les choses en main
sachez qu'outre ne crée double écrit au
fond ce que la voiture recommence
merci